these scientists of the U-turn so I was
basing all my emphatic passionate
rhetoric on what I believe the science
to be another lesson from the pandemic
science evolves facts change they find
out more information I don't think as
some people do that all scientists are
evil I don't think they're deliberately
setting out to mislead people I think
they're trying to get to the truth it
was a novel virus early on when there
were no vaccines and no hope of any
there's never been a coronavirus vaccine
so in those first few months when people
were dying in big numbers there were no
therapeutic drugs really no vaccine and
it looked incredibly serious for mankind
at that point I felt the only answer was
the blunt instrument of a lockdown